breaking news at 6 of barricade inside a
car shutting down a busy intersection
near the strip and now the driver is in
police custody and we have Josh peguero
live at the scene Josh is joining us now
for 8 news now with the very latest
I am standing at Flamingo and Colville
with the eastbound Lanes towards
University Center Drive remains closed
this is a busy intersection during rush
hour traffic and the reason further
closure is that car that you see right
behind me it's a burnt vehicle one
person was arrested as was stated
earlier this started as a barricade
situation Metro Police say around 3 30
they tried pulling over a suspicious
vehicle along Paradise Road that car
then began driving recklessly and the
driver eventually stopped here barricade
himself into the car caught on fire
again one person is arrested we'll bring
you the latest once we receive them from
Metro Police so make sure you monitor
our website 8newsnow.com reporting live
near from lingo and Koval Joshua girl in
news now